oh hey what's up guys mkphd here and
welcome to another video in the tesla
model s p100d video series this one is
going to be about the tesla motors app
so i'm going to be showing you i mean
it's an lte connected car it's a tech
product there's a lot going on there and
there's some cool stuff that the app
does right now but i also want to say
that of course since this is a new tesla
video this is being recorded on the
front-facing camera on the oneplus
3t and if if i'm looking at this video
quality right now i'm just looking back
and forth between the viewfinder and the
camera
looks pretty good i mean you got the
little a little bit of depth of field
going on the background's blurred out
yeah f 2.0 looking pretty good you'll
also be able to see the new video from
the back facing camera which isn't
really a new sensor but there is some
improved electronic image stabilization
that you'll be able to see as well so
let's go and take a look at the app so
right off the bat i do get to address
the fact that this app will probably be
getting a major update within the next
month or so elon musk has already
tweeted and he's he's pretty much who
announces all new tesla products uh that
there's going to be a major update
hopefully new ui hopefully the new
android app gets material design
but this is what it looks like as of
right now and i'll give some suggestions
for what i would like to see but
this is the way the app looks right now
you can see it looks really old ios so
not a whole lot of
ios 10 looks going on here but this is
what you get so right off the bat the
main controls are over here on the side
you can put it in valet mode and valet
mode will actually just super limit the
car's performance so it won't be able to
go super fast super quickly it'll limit
you to 70 miles an hour and essentially
the car is just for valets at that point
so it restricts all your personal
information in the dash doesn't show
your calendar events and you need a pin
code to turn that on or off and there's
also notifications and you can turn
notifications on
well
okay that crashed so that's a good start
for the tesla app you can show
notifications for things like charging
uh when your charging's been interrupted
and other stuff like that apparently
that crashes the app every time hey elon
if you're watching this this app update
is long overdue the fact that it's
crashing on like basic functions like
this is pretty weird it actually works
better on ios than it does on android
but anyway i'll go ahead and show you
the actually cool feature so down here
at the bottom which is easy to reach
since it's a big phone you get all the
main controls for the phone you get to
see where the car is whether it's locked
or unlocked how much range you have left
and that's actually going to look like
your car no matter what color paint or
wheels you get whether you get the
sunroof that'll all be there
and then you can see here this is the
control section where you'll have a vent
roof button that'll just uh vent the
sunroof a little bit but sidenote i
think the vent roof function will be a
lot less used because of the new
software update which monitors the
interior temperature of the car and will
automatically use climate control to
keep the temperature relatively even so
if you're sitting on like had asphalt
hot
hot hot asphalt if you're sitting on hot
asphalt in the summer and the interior
temperature of the car gets up to like
105 degrees it'll automatically cool
that down by either venting or using the
air conditioning so you probably won't
need to use the vent roof function
remotely as much but then the bottom is
kind of the more fun stuff again you can
lock the car if it's unlocked here you
can unlock it if it's locked yes i want
to unlock my vehicle and bam it's just
unlocked behind me and the door handles
came out and then i can also honk the
horn and flash the lights so here's the
lights
they're already on but you can see they
just glowed and here's the horn
geez that's loud all right so moving on
down here at the bottom is your charge
state you can set your charge limit
basically for teslas and all their large
lithium-ion batteries you don't want to
charge them up to a hundred percent
every single time that would be a max
charge of 319 miles i don't need to do
that every single day so unless i'm
going on a road trip i'm going to charge
to about 85 90 percent which is about
280 miles and set that as my charge
limit every night and when i'm charged
and plugging in this will actually show
me how much time i have left until i'm
done charging so if i'm supercharging
it'll show that status i'm charging in
my garage it'll do the same thing and
then over here on the right hand side is
your location that's to literally show
you on a map the location of your car in
case you're trying to remember where you
parked a couple blocks away or if you're
curious about if someone stole your car
or something that'll be your location
and then climate is like i mentioned
earlier you can literally change the
inside temperature of the car right now
the inter
interior temperature is 69 degrees if i
turn on that interior temperature
climate control it'll go ahead and start
to set it to whatever temperature i have
here so 72 degrees and you'll see the
interior graphic turn on when this
finishes loading you'll see the air
start to move into the car
and usually within a couple of minutes
you can fully heat the car there it is
starting fully heat the car or fully
cool down the car before you get into it
so a couple minutes before you leave a
restaurant if you know it's going to be
cold outside or hot outside you can fix
that in the car so there's one button i
haven't pressed yet on the main home
screen and that's
that summon button right there summon
sounds pretty modern summon is like the
most modern version of ghost riding the
whip that's possible right now so right
now with this car's current hardware
it'll be able to move straight forward
and backward using the sensors all
around the car to detect what's near it
and you can choose the summon distance
to be you know 15 feet 20 25 feet and
that's useful for if you're in a garage
and it's a really tight space and this
is kind of like my garage where i can
hit the summon button summon it
backwards and it will summon back out of
my garage without touching any of the
walls without me being in the car at all
so here's what a summon looks like on
the current generation hardware tesla
model s
it wakes up it checks its surroundings
and then it just starts rolling forward
until i tell it to stop or hit the key
fob or walk up and press the door handle
basically it'll just keep going forward
detecting what's around it and uh it
could go all the way over there if i
don't tell it to but right now i think
that's about good
i'll have it stop
and we'll go ahead and deploy the
handles and it is ready to go there's
also something called homelink which
will allow me to connect the car to my
garage door opener so i can reverse out
of my garage with the reverse summon and
i guess the neat part of that is it'll
also open and close the garage door
behind it so if i don't really want to
pull into my garage i can walk up to the
garage
summon it backwards and it'll open the
door behind it come out of the garage
and close the garage door when it's done
summoning which is pretty neat and again
it'll kind of meet you there with the
handles open no one's in the car no
one's controlling it that is the future
so that's pretty much it guys the app is
super simple
super outdated in terms of the way it
looks and i'm looking forward to that
update not only in terms of
functionality but design and hopefully
it doesn't crash anymore either and then
just basic other functions like i'd like
to be able to see like superchargers
nearby that are open in the app i'd like
to be able to have
little things like you know when the
trunk is open for like more than five
minutes if it'll like beep at me and
tell me hey your trunk's been open for a
while little things like that maybe
being able to close the windows from
inside when i know it's about to rain
that would all be a welcome improvement
but until then that is it for the tesla
model s 200d app until that app update
comes and i'll probably make a video
about what's new about it until then
that's been it have a happy holiday if
you're celebrating it thanks for
watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you